let's discuss numeric PDE solving over
regions in Mathematica you have the
functions and dissolve an individual
value to compute solutions of
differential equations in this example
here I use n default value to compute
the solution of a laplacian set equals
to 10 this is a personal type of
equation the dependent variable is U and
x and y are the spatial coordinates
additionally two boundary conditions are
specified at y equals 0 the dependent
variable is set to 0 and at y equals 1
the dependent variable U is set to 1 u
again is the dependent variable and the
region is specified as X going from 0 to
1 and Y going from 0 to 1 initial value
will return an interpolating function
that interpolating function can be used
in functions like plot 3d to visualize
the result to solve PDE s
typically you need to specify three
things you need to specify the region
Omega of course you need a PDE that
you'd like to solve and thirdly you need
to specify boundary conditions that
interact with a PDE and the boundary
here's a second example the region we'd
like to solve the PDE over is a disc
Omega the operator is the negative
laplacian minus 1 and we specify a
derrick a boundary condition that says
that the dependent variable U is
supposed to be 0 for all values of the
region that X is larger than 0 again we
call nd solve value set the PD operator
to 0
give the derelict boundary condition as
an argument
U is a dependent variable and the X&Y
element of Omega which is the disc in
this case again and the solve value will
return the interpolating function and we
can again visualize that solution with
plot 3d notice that in this case the
region was not rectangular was specified
to be a disc
let's discuss the specific PDEs that can
be solved with Md solver and default
value the coefficient form is the most
generic PDE that can be solved it has a
first order time derivative and several
different spatial derivatives if one
looks at specific equations for example
the Laplace equation then the
coefficients that are active are
highlighted in blue in this case in the
Laplace case C is set to 1 and F is set
to 0 a Poisson type equation differs
only in that the right hand side s is
not 0 but a specific value the hummers
equation has an additional term plus a
you a convection reaction type equation
has additional terms beta w plus au a
heat equation is a time-dependent
version a wave equation has a
second-order time derivative and nd
solve will convert higher-order time
derivatives to systems of first order
PDE s these coefficients C alpha beta
gamma and a F can all depend on space
and time let's look at the poisson type
of equation in the picture below you see
a red and a blue boundary will modify
the specific PDE
and the boundary conditions to first use
to deal a boundary conditions on the red
and the blue boundary and then a delay
and the neumann boundary condition let's
set up the problem first we specify an
implicit region that models the exact
region we've seen just now the operator
is a negative laplacian minus 20 and in
this first example we specify that the
dirichlet condition u the dependent
variable is set to 0 at x equals 0 and y
is between 8 and 10 so that's the left
and upper corner of the region we just
saw the secondary condition sets the
dependent variable to 100 and is on the
half circle set on the region
we then call nd self-value with the
operator set to zero the D really
conditions the dependent variable u and
x and y element of Omega and Omega is
the implicit region we visualize the
result UI f is interpolating function
returned by n dissolve and the solution
is depicted below currently we have
three different types of boundary
conditions there are daresay conditions
generalized Norman values and periodic
boundary conditions there the conditions
specified that the dependent variable U
is supposed to have a specific value on
some part of the boundary generalized
norman values specify a flux over an
edge on some part of the boundary also
note that if on some part of the
boundary no boundary condition is
specified then a generalized norman
value of 0 is used as a default and
thirdly we have periodic boundary
conditions those relate the dependent
variable U on specific different part of
the boundary in some relation let's look
at the previous example again we use the
same region and the same PD operator now
we specify a directly condition where we
specify that the dependent variable U is
supposed to be 0 at the specific
boundaries given here that corresponds
to the upper left-hand part of the
region next we specify a normal value on
the semicircle that's the inner part of
the region we can then use N default
value and specify that the operator is
the same as a normal value have the
Dirac Lee condition and use the
dependent variable an x and y are
element of Omega the region specified
previously and we can visualize the
result below let's look at the theory of
boundary conditions
this illustration you see an arbitrary
shaped region which has several
boundaries the outer boundary boundary
one is the outer part of the region then
there's an inner boundary in this
example a hole in the region
that's boundary - and there's this third
boundary that's a material boundary
boundary three daily conditions and
normal values can be applied to specific
parts of the boundary the darish plate
conditions here depicted in blue can be
applied at the outer boundary at inner
boundaries and at material boundaries
Norman values on the other hand can be
applied at under boundaries or at inner
boundaries typically the normal vector
is out what pointing also note that
there's a condition and Norman value
take two arguments the first argument
specifies either the dirty condition or
the Norman value and the second argument
specifies the predicate where on the
boundary that condition is supposed to
be met let's look at the theory of
Norman values for that remind yourself
of the coefficient form we've seen
earlier note that there is a close
correspondence between the Norman value
and the coefficient form I'm going to
try to explain where this correspondence
comes from and why it makes sense for
this we look at a very simplified
version of the finite element derivation
for that the coefficient form is taken
and multiplied by an arbitrary test
function Phi and integrated over that
means that the finite element method
actually tries to find the solution to
the PDE in a weak sense now that
expression is integrated by parts doing
that gives two interesting properties
first note that the derivative on the
function Phi is increased by a 1 but the
differentiability request on this part
of the integral is decreased by 1 also
note that we now have a boundary
integral the crew
can see in this first part of the
expression and in the Boundary
expression is the same as our alpha and
gamma now what happens is that this part
here of the boundary integral is
replaced is substituted with the
definition of the normal value here's an
example for a periodic boundary
condition the region we're looking at is
made up of a rectangle on the left hand
side the disk is added on the right hand
side a disk is subtracted the PD
operator is negative laplacian and it
has an additional load term that load
term is active it gives one if it's
inside the specific part of the region
and zero if it's outside of that region
now periodic boundary conditions take
three arguments first the dependent
variable and the relation of how that
dependent variable at the target is
supposed to relate to the values at the
source the second argument is a
predicate where the periodic boundary
condition is true and the third argument
describes how the values of the
predicate where the predicate is true
are supposed to be transformed to the
source where the dependent variable then
is evaluated and used in the further
computation so what we have here is we
have a target at the blue boundary and
the green bar boundary is where we'd
like to evaluate the dependent variable
U so for this the dependent variable is
specified simply as u the target is
specified at x squared plus y squared
equals 1 and the function X plus 2 comma
0 maps all points from the blue target
to the green source where the final
dependent variable is actually evaluated
at the second boundary condition we have
a DC condition that specifies that the
dependent variable is 0 for the top and
the lower bottom of the region when we
solve this with n be solve we proceed as
before
we specify that the operator is equal to
0 give it the periodic boundary
condition and there is a condition
specify the dependent variable and x and
y are part of the region in the picture
below you see several of those regions
connected together to share the
periodicity of the solution let's look
at the transient problem imagine a pipe
inside the pipe we have a hot liquid and
outside we have room temperature now
additionally in the pipe wall there're
cooling ducts to cool the pipe as such
the specific region that models a
symmetrical part of that pipe is
depicted below in blue and the
mathematical description is given as a
simplicity region
to model this we use the negative
laplacian of the dependent variable u
that now is also time dependent we
specified to directly conditions one on
the inside and one on the outside at the
inside the dependent variable U is set
to 200 and at the outside the dependent
variable U is set to 15 degrees the
normal value models the amount of energy
that's absorbed by the cooling liquid
four times T smaller or equal to ten the
amount slowly grows until it reaches its
maximum now to solve this we call n
dissolve value and specify these
operators at time T equals zero that
will give us a suitable initial
condition for the temporal problem we
then call n dissolve with the time
derivative of the dependent variable U
plus the laplacian operator and set that
equal to the normal value and
additionally specify the daily condition
these are time independent so it doesn't
matter at what time those are specified
additionally we also specify the initial
condition at T equals zero T goes from
zero to 25 and x and y are part of the
region specified above below you see a
visualization of how the cooling liquid
affects the temperature distribution in
the wall of the pipe here's the second
visualization where the contour plot of
the temperature distribution in the pipe
is put back into the original region
that I've shown at the start let's look
at the wave equation the wave equation
has a second order time derivative of
the dependent variable U the special
thing here is that the region is rather
complicated I have a rectangular
boundary and some writing inside of that
boundary what you see a little further
down here is the pov-ray rendering of a
solution of the wave equation in that
domain the letters are a hard boundary
and the wave reflects from
at boundary all of this has been
computed with nd solve only the
rendering has been done with pov-ray
this usually takes about 50,000 elements
and computes in about 5 minutes the
render time is around about 5 hours here
is an animation of that wave equation
problem in that specific region
in the next few slides I'd like to
explain how the wave equation can
interact with different boundary
conditions well that's important to know
how nd solve deals with higher order
time derivatives in general these are
typically converted to systems of first
order so if we have in this example a
second order time derivative in the
dependent variable u equals to some PD
operator that is converted to a first
order time derivative on the dependent
variable u equal to V and auxiliary
variable and that auxiliary variable V
has time derivative which is then set
equal to the PDE operator let's look at
a specific wave equation so we have a
second order time derivative on the
dependent variable u minus the laplacian
we have an initial condition and we said
the derivative of the initial condition
to zero if we solve this with n dissolve
and animate the solution we get the
following we see that the wave first out
and gets reflected at the boundaries
this may be what you want but it may
also not be what you want in this second
example we set the derivative the
temporal derivative of the dependent
variable u to 0 that is specifying
Normand value for the auxiliary variable
as shown earlier so an absorbing
boundary condition can thus be modeled
now when the wave runs out it's absorbed
at the boundaries
in this third example would try to use
periodic absorbing boundary conditions
the problem set up is similar to before
with the only difference that now that
the derivative on the initial condition
is actually specified to have an initial
velocity on the web so the wave is
moving to the right in this specific
case we specify a periodic boundary
condition where the dependent variable U
is supposed to be taken from the
right-hand side and mapped to the
left-hand side looking at the solution
we see that the wave moved to the right
and re-enters on the left-hand side and
dissolve can solve systems of NPDES in
this example I've chosen two PDE s with
dependent variables U and V the two
equations are in principle exactly the
same as the coefficient form given
earlier with the only difference that
each of the equation depends on the two
dependent variables U and V this allows
for cross coupling between the different
components in the PDE s and allows for
great variety of PDE s
to be solved the dear clear conditions
now also depend on U and V as do the
normal values at another example let's
look at Stokes flow Stokes flow is a
system of three coupled to PDE s and
they're depicted below we have U and V
as velocity components and P as a
pressure the example will act to analyze
now is a narrowing channel on the left
hand side depicted in red here we have
an inflow boundary condition that
specifies the velocity in the U
direction the U Direction is equivalent
to the X direction and on the right hand
side we specify a pressure zero at the
outflow let's start with the problem set
up first we specify the region Omega
with an implicit region then we specify
the PDE Stokes
is a function that's appended at the end
of this notebook and will return three
PDEs
that we've seen just before on the
previous slide you V P and the dependent
variables were you and B are the x and y
velocity components and P is the
pressure we set that to zero in all
three dependent components thirdly we
specified the dairy state boundary
conditions
the first area condition is on the
left-hand edge the inflow condition and
it specifies that the velocity in the U
direction is given by the formula shown
the second equation the secondary shape
condition is that U and V are both said
to be zero between the inflow and the
outflow so all boundary walls have a
zero velocity component in U and V
direction and the last Erika condition
specifies the pressure at the outflow P
is set to zero here to solve this we
call nd self-value with the specified
PDE and the boundary conditions u v NP
are the dependent variables and in
default value we'll return three
interpolating functions x and y are part
of omega the region we just specified
and additionally we specified that the
method to be used as a finite element
method and specify that the
interpolation order for u and V two
dependent variables is second order and
the interpolation order for P the
pressure is first-order that is a
stabilization technique comment in the
finite element world lastly there is a
visualization of the velocity field of
the inflow and the outflow part of the
component let's look at the 3d
structural mechanics problem we have a
graphics of a crankshaft that crankshaft
is held fixed at both ends and forces
from the piston deform object
the problem setup we first used
discretized graphics to convert the
graphics into something that two element
mesh then can generate element mesh from
the mesh order is set to one and this
says that the approximation is first
order accurate this generates a mesh of
a hundred and seventy-five thousand
tetrahedra you don't have to use two
element mesh to generate the mesh but
you can and in this case I've just done
this to illustrate you that it's
possible to do it
second we set up the PDE and the
boundary conditions the stress operator
is given at the end of the notebook it
takes Young's modulus and poissons ratio
UV and W s dependent variables and XY
and Z at the spatial coordinates this
will return a set of three coupled PD es
the first two are set to zero and the
last one gets a normal value with a
value of minus 1000 this means that the
force is pushing in the negative Z
direction at the given positions thirdly
we give the directly conditions where we
say that UV and W are set to zero
they're held fixed as both ends of the
crank shaft MD solve will then solve
this PD and boundary conditions in about
six seconds on this specific laptop the
visualization shows the deformed
crankshaft in red in this section we're
going to discuss numeric eigen value
problems to solve numeric eigen value
problems you typically need two or three
things you need a PDE a region
specification and sometimes boundary
conditions the PDE is given in exactly
the same coefficient form that nd solve
an ND solve value take with a slight
exception that you don't have a right
hand side ad but a lambda u where lambda
is the eigen value boundary conditions
do not always need to be given if
they're not given the problem is
unconstrained and if you specify
boundary conditions it's a constraint
eigenvalue problem here's a simple
example let's look at the negative
laplacian to do so we use the function
and the eigen system- laplacian you use
the dependent variable and exist a
spatial coordinate
and in the region of X from zero to PI
and we'd like to compute for eigenvalues
and for eigenvectors those are returned
in valves and fonts the vowels are
depicted below and those are the four
eigenvalues computers for this system
plot shows the visualization of the
eigenfunctions here's the second example
in 2d again we compute the negative
laplacian urug is again the dependent
variable x and y other spatial
coordinates this is a constraint
eigenvalue problem as we specify rdf:li
condition and specify that u is supposed
to be 0 all on the boundary U is the
dependent variable and X&Y
are part of a disc and we'd like to
compute 6i ghen values and 6i ghen
functions the eigenvalues for this
system are shown here and below our
plots of the eigenfunctions create an
application example where we try to
compute the acoustic eigen modes of a
car for that I've downloaded a picture
from the capito the picture shows a mini
which has been cut in half I use the
image processing math tool to generate a
boundary graphics that is the black
picture with the white boundary below I
then use the function bound to
discretize graphics of that boundary
which gives me a boundary mesh region I
can directly feed that boundary mesh
region 2 nd eigen system and in order to
compute the acoustic eigen modes i
compute the negative laplacian the eigen
system of the negative laplacian use the
dependent X&Y our spatial coordinates
and I'd like to compute 6 ion values and
6 icon functions next you see the second
eigen mode overlaid over the car blue
areas are low acoustic pressure and red
areas are high acoustic pressure let's
summarize the capabilities of numeric
PDE solving over regions we can solve
PDS with linear variable coefficients
trends and systems eigen systems and the
PD es over these arbitrary regions can
be in one
a 2d and 3d thank you very much for
attending we hope you enjoyed it